squid squid just when you thought my
intros couldn't get any worse you just
had to one-up yourself for the finale
didn't you congratulations you plays
yourself yes the final episode of season
one's Watchmen is here and holy crap is
it a bad day to be a white supremacist
in this video we're gonna break down the
episode and you're gonna want to stick
around till the very end as we'll be
going over some of this season's biggest
unanswered questions and what it could
mean for season 2 there's also a secret
link if you hover your mouse over a
certain word in the latest PD PD article
and I'll be going over that as well so
let's get into it we begin on a film
slate fitting since Adrian Veidt is
recording his message to the future
President of the United States Robert
Redford this is the year 1985 however
Redford won't be given this recording
until January of 1993 when he'll be
inaugurated as president notice how all
the crew here at veidt's antarctic base
are Vietnamese we later learn they're
refugees from the war and Adrian has
taken them in most likely because
they're the only ones he can trust we've
seen how the Vietnamese hate dr.
Manhattan and the occupying US forces so
it makes sense that Veidt would take
them in as they both have a common goal
in getting rid of the doc on his desk
you can make up these little Ozymandias
figurines just like in the comic later
on in the episode he'll even become
frozen like one were then introduced to
Lady trues real mother of Vietnamese
refugee working as a cleaning lady for
vite it's implied through young Bien's
dreams that the real bien was a survivor
from an American attack during the war
which left her village burned to the
ground
an attack likely perpetrated by Eddie
Blake the comedian and his squadron the
blazing commandos who were known for
burning down villages bien knows
Adrian's password Ramses the second the
same password he has in the comics
Ramses the second was regarded as one of
the greatest Egyptian pharaohs and we
know how adrian has a hard-on for
Egyptian history as well as Alexander
the Great he even keeps vials of semen
behind a picture of him and that's what
she's here for on the computer interface
we get these prompts of tying and
untying the knot which is a reference to
the Gordian knot
and the Gordian knot itself and not only
Alexander the Great could untie beyond
retrieves vial number 2346
I mean it must get a little lonely down
there in Antarctica and we know Adrienne
doesn't partake in sex
so jerking off over two thousand times
seems reasonable right before preparing
her [ __ ] gun BM recites the ancient myth
of lady true which tells the legend of a
Vietnamese woman who was able to fight
off the invading Chinese army beyond
will later give birth the lady true who
shows up on Karnak in the year 2008
saying she's Adrienne's daughter you
here we see the episodes title see how
they fly which is a lyric from the
Beatles song I am The Walrus which plays
at the end of the episode true knows
that Adrienne was behind the
transdimensional attack in 85 probably
because her mother told her she's been
spending her time building a quantum
centrifuge a machine that would allow
her to take dr. Manhattan's powers so
she can actually make some change in the
world like end world hunger and stop
wars for good
Adrian interrupts however telling her
that won't be possible considering dr.
Manhattan is all the way on Mars but
true has launched probes into space
which can detect a specific type of
radioactive energy that Manhattan emits
and she's found that he's on Europa a
moon of Jupiter the only problem is she
needs 42 billion dollars to construct
that quantum centrifuge Adrian is not
keen on the idea like him she needs to
make her own way she needs to prove that
she can achieve these things on her own
he sends her off saying he'll never call
her daughter but as we find out later on
in the episode he eventually does true
even acknowledges the effort it took to
write the word daughter instead of
saying true which has less letters you
took the time to spell out daughter
it meant a lot to be acknowledged back
on Europa we see veidt's cake has seen
better days he's used the horseshoe he
acquired from it to dig his way out
waiting for trues pod to whisk him away
a horseshoe that has been whittled down
sharp and will later be used to stab the
game warden as we'll find out the game
warden was veidt's creation so he could
have an adversary while he was there
something that would keep himself from
going mad they had planned this all
along that's why we have Phillips
mistakenly give him a horseshoe in
Episode one so this plan was hatched
several years ago I'm hoping to come up
with a timeline video sometime tomorrow
so I'll chronologically place all these
events together so if you're not
subscribed yet make sure to do that and
stay tuned
there's also another fun little nod here
of Adrian catching the bullet in the
graphic novel Veidt successfully catches
a bullet after Laurie fires at him now
does he actually have this crazy power
or did Adrian rigged the game wardens
gun I guess we'll never know poor game
warden asked if he was a worthy
adversary and Ozzy says no his real
adversary will later be his own daughter
it's kind of ironic that the person who
ends up foiling trues plan is this same
person she helped rescue millions of
miles away in the pod we learned that
the golden statue found in Lady trues
vivarium was actually Adrian Veidt all
along frozen like Han Solo in carbonite
she's been waiting until their plan
nears its completion to unfreeze him so
he can witness everything she's
accomplished on her own no less they
pack on up to the town square where she
picks up a newspaper which she's been
collecting for her time capsule then we
have this giant floating quantum
centrifuge thing emerging the device
that will destroy Manhattan and allow
true to take on his powers Veidt also
says this cryptic line
her seed is Palestine has become a widow
it's from an ancient inscription on the
Merneptah stele this inscription was
found across the Nile from Karnak and
Merneptah was the son of ramses ii the
passage tells of a man who will stop at
nothing to become God or die trying
kind of like lady true at the abandoned
mall members of cyclops congregate
including senator Keens father Lori who
is still tied up is visited by Looking
Glass who has come to acquire something
this something will later find is the
tape implicating Adrianne to the 1985
squid attack on New York Manhattan is
teleported into a synthetic lithium cage
a material that suppresses his powers
synthetic lithium could be found in
electronic watch batteries and were
banned by President Redford since it was
believed they had caused cancer that's
why all the way back in episode 1 we see
the 7th cavalry collecting them it's
also interesting that when Keane talks
to his people they sit on the church set
like he's preaching to the choir
everyone else Angela lookingglass and
Lori are off to the side Keane goes on a
lengthy monologue about how puppet
president Redford has diminished the
white man standing in the world and he's
here to reclaim it by becoming both
president and God way back during the
white night we learned that Manhattan
didn't kill the man who was about to
kill Angela rather that he was
teleported to New Mexico
this meant Keane in the 7th cavalry new
Manhattan was in Tulsa allowing Judd and
Jane to infiltrate and keep a watch on
him while they devised a way to trap him
Angela arrives and tells Keene not to go
through with whatever he's doing lady
true knows of his plan and if he tries
to do something it will assuredly
backfire you see the 7th cavalry has
been stealing these batteries from true
but that was all part of trues plan when
Keene gets into his panties the same
kind that Manhattan wore when he was
destroying Vietnam he ventures into his
chamber which sets off a blast that
transports everyone into the town square
and liquefies Keene in the process as
true goes on to say absorbing atomic
energy without filtering at first will
pop you like a balloon true is revealed
as this season's true villain ha ha
her minions using these powerful
netic shields to disarm the seventh
cavalry and the others she not keen will
be the next dr. Manhattan and the first
thing she's going to do is get rid of
these white supremacists starting with
those in the square true also tells
Angela that Cal was the price her
grandfather had to pay for justice will
wanted to end Cyclops in the seventh
cavalry but needed to give up Cal in
order to do so that was the betrayal he
referred to in Episode four the traitor
and in three days Adrienne is also
reunited with Lori they used to work
together as part of the Watchmen and
she's none too thrilled oh yeah she also
tried to kill him he tells her that the
end is nigh which is the same thing
Rorschach has on his side in the comics
Keynes gu is used by Manhattan to
teleport Laurie Adrian and lookingglass
to Karnak this is all part of an
elaborate plan to freeze the squid reign
so that when it drops it will destroy
anything in its path including throughs
floating machine true NBN amp up the
machine and Manhattan begins to lose his
power angela is there by his side as he
says for cryptic lines all from the
novel all we ever see of stars are their
old photographs this is when dr.
Manhattan was on Mars remembering his
own origin story are you cold
the tomb this is a reference to his
first love Janey Slater when they
celebrated Christmas together as far as
I know there is no situation in
Afghanistan currently require my
attention this occurs when he's being
interviewed by ABC and finally
this happens in 1977 when Manhattan
teleports a bunch of protesters outside
the White House but perhaps the most
cryptic line dr. Manhattan says to
Angela is about her not touching the
light now this could mean literally the
light which beams down on him or it
could hint at something to come in
season 2 dr. Manhattan's energy has
zapped and an explosion throws Angela
back in a scene that mimics the
explosion she was in as a child
meanwhile back at karnak adrian tells
lookingglass to freeze the squid while
he prepares to dump them on tulsa
looking glass is pretty pissed at Adrian
since his entire life was changed by
that catastrophic event in 1985 Adrian
knows that Manhattan is already dead but
there's still time to stop true anyone
who seeks to attain the power of a god
must be prevented at all costs from
attaining Tulsa PD arrives along with
Red Scare and pirate Jenny as the ice
squid rained down one even goes through
throughs hand her quantum centrifuge is
completely destroyed and the thing that
became her life's masterwork ends up
being the thing that kills her
I guess Lori's joke to dr. Manhattan
about a god being killed by space junk
has come true we also get this little
bit of symbolism as the cross holding
Jesus falls down beside lady true she
won't be becoming a god any time soon
angela rushes to the dreamland theatre
where will and the kids are will tells
her that this whole thing was dr.
Manhattan's plan and betraying her was
all part of it but more importantly he
tells her that it isn't anger under that
mask but fear and hurt you can't heal
under a mask and he also mentions the
line you kidding me about making it come
a line that will later trigger Angela to
attempt walking on water when she sees
the unbroken egg last episode we learned
dr. Manhattan can transfer his powers
through organic material if he did so
with the egg could Angela become the new
dr. Manhattan and the answer is yes but
will it happen according to Damon
Lindelof in rolling stone he believes
that either scenario whether she ends up
walking on the water or sinks wouldn't
make for riveting television in fact
season two hasn't been greenlit by HBO
but this decision has more to do with
Lindelof finding a good story to tell
rather than HBO waiting to see ratings
he's apparently going to come back to
work in January to see whether season 2
is viable since season 1 was supposed to
be a self-contained season Lindelof is
also open for someone else to take over
the show and even setting a season in a
different decade like the 50 60s or even
the future but if the show does end up
taking off from season 1 I like to think
that dr. Manhattan isn't gone for good
according to the law of the conservation
of energy energy cannot be created nor
destroyed Manhattan's energy was taken
from him but where did it go
it was never transferred to true and we
also know that Manhattan could
theoretically put himself back together
like he did originally in our final
scene with Laurie lookingglass and
Adrian we see that Adrian has kept
Archie the flying ship used as the
original design for the flying police
vehicle we saw in episode 1 this was dan
dreiberg AKA night owls creation night
owl and Laurie had a thing back in the
day but according to PD PD a night owl
is currently doing time in prison and
speaking of prison that's where Laurie
says a train is going
I wonder if Adrian does end up in prison
if we'll finally meet night owl in
season 2 it would be so cool to see a
prison just reserved for mass vigilantes
I think that would be an awesome idea
Angela and the others emerge from the
dreamland theatre and you can make out
the dr. M illuminated in the background
pirate Jenny and Red Scare have taken
off their masks for the first time are
their masks even needed anymore now that
these 7th cavalry have been defeated oh
what a beautiful morning plays in the
background which is the first song in
the musical Oklahoma which was playing
at the dreamland I also like this shot
of Topher finally realizing his mother
is the masked vigilante sister night it
echoes a long tradition in their family
where they young are influenced by their
costume wielding elders like young will
wearing his father's uniform his son
watching him his hooded justice and
Angela watching her father in his army
uniform Topher is the next generation as
Angela prepares to Jesus walk on the
water after eating the egg The Beatles I
am The Walrus plays which is based off a
Lewis Carroll poem named the walrus and
the carpenter'
the poem is about a walrus and a
carpenter who wished for a beach to be
beautiful but end up destroying it in
the process it's a story that men
dr. Manhattan in Adrian Veidt but I know
what you're all here for what the hell
happened to Lube man well in the final
PD pedia entry we learned that PDP dia
has been shut down with Agent P D being
fired when he refused to go back to
Washington instead staying in Tulsa to
investigate the deaths of Senator Kean
and lady true in his office they found a
jug of canola oil and if you click on
the word canola oil in the PDF document
a link leads to this as I stated in my
episode 4 video it's clear that agent P
D is Lube man and if he's still in Tulsa
expect him to make a slippery return in
season 2 oh god these puns in an
interview with vulture Lindelof went on
to say that Luo man's identity was a
reward for those who read PD PDF so I
think we can close the books on this one
so now I open it up to you what do you
think of the season and what did I miss
I want to hear your thoughts in the
comments below I have more Watchmen
videos coming out so make sure to LIKE
and subscribe you can also follow me on
twitter at think story whitey until next
time remember daddy loves you very much